hey Gary how's it going my name is
adoring a deck I make youtube videos and
i created the twitter account OMG facts
now i control and manage a network of
many different accounts on many
different social platforms and my
question for you today is do you believe
creating my own website with valuable
original content to drive traffic to is
a reasonable investment for long-term
branding or do you believe that websites
are going to be irrelevant eventually
with this mobile revolution that's
happening should I be looking more into
app development or something that I'm
not even looking at let me know thanks I
think it's a really good question a lot
of people are struggling with I will say
this you know I have Gary Vaynerchuk
calm oh no you can't look it out
lengthen anyway I've Gary ownership calm
for a reason not for kicks and giggles I
want to have a platform that I
fundamentally control all aspects of and
so you know when you're building brand
on Twitter with a bunch of Twitter
accounts like you are like I am when
you're building a facebook fan page you
know some Facebook themes for itself and
for its audience and for you believe it
or not that they need to drop down
organic reach and everything you're
putting out is not being delivered you
start understanding why having your own
email service having your own website
matters having your own app matters if
you deem that people are going to spend
more of their time within the app then
on a mobile native website just because
the world's going mobile or risky or or
this you know or virtual reality doesn't
necessarily mean that the website is
gone it's really just a protocol for a
place that you can own and so what I
would say is philosophically you want to
have your own house but doing business
in your vacation home or in a hotel also
matter if you understood that analogy
you're on your way